this video was made possible by
hellofresh
go to hellofresh.com and use code
wendover14 to get 14 free meals
plus free shipping this
isn't really the united states this map
while it may display the technical
internationally recognized borders of
the country
just as not fully accurate
it should look more like this that's
because
the 89 000 square miles or 230 000
square kilometers now missing from this
map
are filled by 326 indian reservations
and the native american tribes that
manage these lands are recognized by the
u.s federal government
as sovereigns that's to say well these
may not be countries
they are by most measures independent
sovereign nations collectively
reservations account for two and a half
percent of the us's total land mass
and together would represent the 12th
physically largest state
between michigan and minnesota truly the
only commonality between each of the
reservations is the system through which
they are recognized by the u.s federal
government
they range dramatically in size system
and function the smallest for example is
the likely ranchera in northern
california
at just 1.32 acres it's physically
similar in size to many suburban home
plots
and is used as the cemetery of the pitt
river tribe
there are also plenty of larger
reservations without any permanent
population
for example the antagon indian
reservation in michigan's upper
peninsula
is mainly used by a branch of the lake
superior chipewa tribe as hunting and
fishing lands
and the small snow quality reservation
is almost entirely composed
of the tribe's casino but of course a
majority of reservations are inhabited
by anywhere between
1 and 174 000 people
at the upper end of that spectrum
there's the physically largest
most populous and by many measures most
politically developed indian reservation
the navajo nation centered around
northeastern arizona
but passing into utah and new mexico as
well the navajo nation
is physically larger than 10 u.s states
and has a population greater than that
of 18
un-recognized countries now according to
the u.s
the navajo nation is sovereign but it's
certainly
not a country so what is it
now like all indian reservations the
story of how the navajo nation came to
be
is complex and tragic its dna people
have inhabited the southwest
since their migration from arctic
america around the 15th century a.d
but the path that directly led to the
establishment of the reservation
began with the long walk after years of
conflict between european americans and
the dna
the u.s federal government directed the
army to end what was
in their eyes the navajo problem
soldiers descended on navajo land
destroying much of their civilization
and one by one forced bands of dna to
walk
400 miles or 650 kilometers from their
homelands to fort sumner in new mexico
where they were imprisoned on cramped
unproductive land
hundreds died during the walk and
thousands more
while imprisoned after a few years
though the government recognized that
they had made a mistake
the camp was costly to run due to its
low agricultural yields
and they realized the land from which
the dna had come was not what the us
would consider
useful for its settlers in exchange for
a number of provisions aimed at
assimilation the navajo and the u.s
signed the treaty of bosque danto ending
the internment
and effectively establishing the navajos
reservation around
their homelands still though in the
decades that followed
the reservation looked a little like the
nation of today
change accelerated in 1921 though when
the aztec oil syndicate
struck oil one mile south of the town of
aztec new mexico
this would go on to be developed into
the first commercial well in the region
attracting considerable attention
nationwide while this first site was
outside the reservation
large oil companies soon recognized that
there were almost
certainly productive sites within navajo
borders u.s secretary of the interior
albert bacon fall
who was quite friendly with the oil and
gas industry and later would become
the first presidential cabinet member in
history to go to jail after accepting
bribes from the industry
recognized that further oil and gas
development in the region
would require the navajo system of
governance to look a little more like
the us's
at the time the reservation was
administered through a decentralized
somewhat informal traditional form of
governance which made negotiations with
big american companies
difficult therefore fall organized a
navajo business council
with three positions filled by three of
his appointees
all of whom were navajo but also friends
of fall
or the industry however bureau of indian
affairs commissioner charles h
burke recognized that this was far from
a democratic process
an unelected council making decisions on
behalf of all the dna people
so he worked to set up an elected tribal
council
the new core of the nation's legislative
system
still today that council serves the same
purpose
but its establishment snowballed the
navajo government into something far
more formal sprawling and western
the sovereignty of the navajo nation is
best examined through its capital
window rock its streets are lined with
the offices
of all the agencies and organizations
running the government functions that
the navajo nation handles itself
the division of public safety the window
rock police department the office of
community development
the navajo nation veterans
administration the navajo housing
authority the navajo nation
telecommunications and utility agency
the fish and wildlife department the
heritage and historic preservation
office
the tribal courts the supreme court the
office of vital records the council
chambers
and the navajo nation office of the
president and vice president
many similarly named structures could
also be found in county
state and national capitals across the
u.s and world
but there are some missing also dotting
the landscape of window rock
are features like a branch of the united
states postal service an office of the
arizona motor vehicle department
arizona state route 264 maintained by
the arizona department of transportation
in an airport administered and regulated
by the american faa adding to that one
sees many of the chain services and
stores
of the united states aflac h r block
ace hardware wells fargo chevron bank of
america
quality inn mcdonald's and more however
there is also a small unique business
landscape
there are navajo petroleum gas stations
owned by the navajo oil and gas company
of the same name
basha's dna market which while owned and
operated by the region-wide bosch's
brand is a unique sub-brand carrying
goods especially in demand by dna like
bluebird flour and mutton
and there's the navajo times which while
originally ran by the government
is now a for-profit financially
independent newspaper
so the government and economy of the
navajo nation is an amalgamation of
navajo and american features
so considering that can it be considered
truly independent independence
is defined by a lack of dependence so
the answer to that
revolves around their relationship with
the us the federal government's official
terminology as to what tribal
reservations are
is quote domestic dependent nations
while that term originates from an 1831
supreme court case
it's never used elsewhere to define what
any other geopolitical entity is
either in the u.s or internationally so
it's rather
ill-defined therefore for all intents
and purposes
domestic dependent nation is essentially
interchangeable with the term
indian reservation while what an
american state is
is well understood and defined what an
indian reservation is
is defined by a patchwork of decisions
guidelines legislation
and treaties for example the indian
citizenship act of 1924
made us so that all remaining indigenous
people living in the u.s
not already a citizen would be granted
such status meaning
functionally that all those living on
tribal nations are obligated to pay
taxes to the u.s federal government
as the u.s uniquely taxes on citizenship
and not residency
however when members of tribes live on
tribal land
they do not pay taxes to the states that
that land is also a part of
window rock for example is technically
part of both arizona
and the navajo nation but its residents
only pay taxes to the latter
the tribes themselves and therefore the
reservations do not pay taxes to either
state or
federal governments much like individual
american states
themselves unlike states however tribal
nations have something similar
to a citizenship system each tribe has
the power to define who can become
members and what the process of
enrollment
looks like for example in the case of
the navajo nation
members need to be at least one fourth
dna by lineage
and not a member of any other tribe
building on that
private property is essentially
non-existent on tribal nations
the land is held in trust by the u.s
federal government
and then managed by the tribal
governments therefore
most residents either live in homes
rented out by the tribal housing
authority
or in mobile homes on public lands
that's because banks won't give loans to
build housing within reservations
as the land upon which they'd be built
is publicly owned
so it'd be impossible to repossess the
homes if payments
fell behind they will loan for mobile
homes since they can be repossessed more
easily
but altogether the policy of public land
ownership
effectively means tribal nations have
immigration control
you can only live in the navajo nation
for example if you qualify
for government housing and you only
qualify for government housing if you're
either dna or working in the nation
adding to this during the covet pandemic
the navajo nation
enacted some of the strictest border
restrictions in the united states
essentially prohibiting access to all
non-residents except when passing
through on state highways
and received no strong legal opposition
to such action
so altogether the navajo and other
tribal nations have a level of power
over who can live and visit their
territory
that eclipses that of individual us
states
however there are other ways in which
these nations
parallel states for example the u.s
federal government
instructs its agencies to treat any
interaction with tribal nations as quote
government to government also like
states tribal nations cannot engage in
formal relations with foreign
governments
enter into a state of war or issue
currency all key differentiators between
nationhood
and countryhood however somewhat unlike
states
the navajo nation has this a washington
office
this functions somewhat like the offices
of different state representatives in dc
however the navajo nation washington
office is closer to an
embassy than these as it exclusively
serves to represent the nation through
non-voting means to the u.s government
and its agencies
the navajo nation wasn't the first to
attempt to represent itself in
washington
in 1995 the chickasaw nation of oklahoma
appointed charles w blackwell as the
first tribal ambassador to the u.s
in addition they opened what they called
a chickasaw nation embassy
in dc now neither the ambassador nor the
embassy had the diplomatic protections
of those of foreign nations
so it's unclear how legitimate they were
but there were no challenges to the
nation setting up
such a representative system the
cherokee nation
also of oklahoma is now going a step
further as they believe that they have a
legal right to formal representation
in washington an 1835 treaty with the
u.s
gave the charoking nation the power to
send a non-voting representative
to the u.s congress similar to those
appointed by the district of columbia
and u.s territories
until 2019 the charoki never appointed
such a representative
but now decided to exercise their rights
when they appointed kimberly tihi to
fill the position
however as of june 2021 she has yet to
be seated by congress
meaning her power is not yet formalized
while it appears the nation has every
legal right to take such action
it's a potentially messy situation as
the people of the churoki tribe
already have representation in congress
while dc and the territories do not
receive voting congressional
representation
the turoki do as they live in oklahoma
which
as a state has voting members in
congress
having people represented twice in
congress would be unprecedented
it's unclear as of now whether ti will
be seated but the reality is that this
situation is like many
involving tribal powers in the us they
don't know what they can
do until they try in fact
that was exactly what happened in the
1970s when russell and helen bryan of
the chippewa nation
received a property tax bill for around
200 from a county government
despite the fact that they were living
on tribal lands having never received
such a bill before
and not believing they were required to
pay it they brought it to a local lawyer
who brought their case to the state
courts they lost that case
and they then lost their appeal in the
minnesota supreme court but then they
brought it to the united states supreme
court
their decision said that not only do
states lack the power to tax tribal
members on their reservations
but that states don't have the power to
regulate any tribal activity
on their nations this was huge
an idea soon arose as to how to profit
from this decision
quite quickly small-scale gambling
operations sprung up on reservations
and within years large tribal casinos
started
opening today these casinos generate
tens of billions of dollars in revenue
for tribal nations annually
especially for those lucky enough to be
located near major metro areas where
gambling is illegal such as the chippewa
nation
which operates the largest casino in
america just 90 minutes from dallas
others such as the navajo nation are
less
lucky located far from economic
opportunity
their unemployment rate is 49 their
average household income
is 8 000 dollars their poverty rate is
36 percent
and one-third of their households lack
access to running
water tribal reservations in the us
exist in a sort of in between states
some sovereign powers are greater than
those of states
but they lack the true level of
self-determination reserved for
countries
however being in such a lonely club
these reservations don't receive the
attention necessary to reform a system
that
in many cases works against them
for example the system of public
ownership of land means that it's
essentially impossible for those living
on reservations to own their own
home that means they can't build up
wealth through home ownership
and pass it on to the next generation
reservations are located in some of the
most
rural areas of the us in places already
experiencing the effects of
deep rural urban economic divide but
being isolated from the system of states
and ignored by the federal government
due to their political irrelevance
they perpetually fall into the category
of not
my problem while there is opportunity
in sovereignty it cannot be realized
without trying
and trying new things is effectively
impossible for places so deeply
entrenched in a cycle
of poverty so the answer to what the
navajo nation
or any native american reservation is is
that nobody knows
they're what the federal government lets
them be and so far
there hasn't been enough time or money
for them
to explore their boundaries
so just over a year ago i realized
something
i had become a takeout and delivery
addict
being a busy person by the time i got to
dinner every day i was tired and ready
to just relax
so i would default to the easiest most
convenient option for food
however eventually i realized the huge
downsides of takeout and delivery
it's incredibly expensive when done
regularly and generally just not
very healthy so i switched to hello
fresh
this is all completely true and i have
hundreds of their recipe cards to prove
it as i've now used them regularly for
just
over a year so a few months ago i asked
them to sponsor the channel
and now they have every week a new
hellofresh box arrives on my doorstep
filled with pre-proportioned ingredients
for each meal i picked from the dozens
of choices they have
each week for example this week i made
one of my favorites
the firecracker meatballs since their
meals come with the right ingredients in
the right amounts
they only take about 30 minutes to make
and you don't have to make long
exhausting trips to grocery stores
also since you're only getting the
amounts you actually need hellofresh
helps cut down on food waste and their
carbon footprint is about 25
lower than that of store-bought meals
altogether
hellofresh just makes my dinner a much
more enjoyable experience
so find out why i've been using them for
over a year go to hellofresh.com and use
code wendover14 to get 14 free meals
plus free shipping